What's up gamers!
It's yo boi...
PEWDIEPAAAA
WAHOO
Today we're playing
....I honestly don't remember
This. is so. fricking. cool guys
I cannot tell you guys how excited I-
How excited I am to play this game.
Create a- oh my god is that me?
Is that me? Can I-
Can I kiss?
Hello there!
Let's not make it awkward, we just got started, Felix
I'm a blue eyes, white dragon
*INB4 MEDIA CALLS ME RACISM*
*BECAUSE I MADE A BLACK CHARACTER*
Listen, I gotta play it safe these days
WOAH
OOOOOOOOOOOOH
SHJIT ITS YOU MAN
YOU *Freaking* ROCK MAN
you da best
you da man
that's right
god damn boi
this is not about
me customizing my medieval characters
this is about
sexism in vide-
*Now thats what this all about.*
i can frickin jump super high
oh that freaks me out
WOAH
HOH
OAH
OH
OH MY GOD that FREAKS me out dude
I never done that
OH
woa oh *laughing*
woah
wooah
oh and its slow motion too
woah
I'm in slow motion, guys!
waah
oh dude I can have like different stances and sh-
that's so-
OW
How you doin' baby?
You ever fight with a man this handsome before?
Oh
en garde!
EN GARDEE
YEAH BOY WHAT CHU WANT
Im frickin outta here guys ..
woah
dude
even buckets got nothing on me
woah WAAOH
WOAH
THIS IS SO COOL
HAH
*explosion*
chose destination on the map
alright
lets go.. ruins
I can't wait to play this.. this is so cool
I have not played a VR game like this
maybe Gorn
if you guys remember that
aw jeez
it looks like
*Shiliiing*
it looks like I'm in dark souls
OH DUDE there's like
theres like a bunch of stuff over here
WOAH
aw dude
this is what we have in Sweden
this is what we call the viking stance
*Viking music plays*
come at me!
from the fyrjyorge!
okay.. ah okay
so arena
lets put it on uhh, the hardest
special mode, what does that mean?
heh heh heh
okay. uhh
Kinda hard to point when your arm is-
I'm putting it on the "hardest"
Dude can you wait for my arm - wait for my arm to spawn.
Wait for my arm -  GOD DAMMIT.
Alright.
whatchu got? HUH?
HWHUA!
AH!
HWHA!
*murdering noises*
HUHAHHHH!
I got your pussy ass boyfriend.
DON'T EVEN TRY IT!
Shield time!
AH GOD you're still alive!
S-stop, STOP FIGHTING.
AH!
Ah! You crazy!
You're crazy
You're crazy!
I'm freakin dying over here guys-
*coughs*
Ahh
EH
Oh god
Erh god I'm gonna die!
I DONT WANNA DIE (Voice Crack)
woOAHHHH!
WOOA
WOAAHH
WOOOOH
You can't stop the Swedes!
AHHH!
Oh- Oh- I got 'em!
AH!
STOP!
Anybody STOP!
I CAN'T SEE ANYTHING!
I can't see anything-
honestly, where am I?
Alright,
that doesn't count!
Alright, bucket
I summon thee
ohhh AHHHH!
AHHH!
HOW DID THAT HAPPEN!?
WOAH!
OH MY GOD I'M the emperor from the Star Wars
*YEGHHHHH*
*EYAAHHH*
*EHHHHHGHHHhhhhhhhh!*
ahHH!
Ah!
EHh!
Ayh!
*AAAAAHHHHHHHH!*
HhuH!
HA Ha ha ha!
*ERHRHHRHRHRH!*
REH!
PHah!
I expect you to die!
*Lightning*
YEahh!
EHhh!
Muehh!
OH, JESUS CHRIST!
JESUS,
what's wrong with you?
DON'T shhneak up on a man!
With-
Alright, back off. I'm getting weapons.
back off
You're making me VERY ANGRY!
YOU DO NOT WANT TO MAKE SWEDISH MAN-
*talks in Swedish*
OKAY
SUMMON the-
I have the DJAGGER!
I have the Dagger of Distance!
The Dagger of Distance!
Oh, ah, oh
YEAH! DAgger of DIStance!
[?]
Ey!
Hey!
SIT THE *Demonetize* DOWN *Demonetize*!
What are ya doing?
Come here!
*talks in Swedish*
I SEE YA!
OH!
don't EVEN!
don't even!
don't eve-
STOP!
Stop!
Stop it!
OH *Demonetize*!
It went right throuugghh!
Alright, it's-
This is an interesting stance.
OH MY GOD!
OKAY!
THAT'S easier!
let's do, ahh-
medium, Wave II.
I wanna try the kick, this time.
[?]
HAH!
HAAH!
*speaks in Swedish*
DHAA!
ah-
*speaks in Swedish*
*more Swedish*
AWH *Demonetize*!
*Lightning*
SIT THE *Demonetize* DOWN *Demonetize*!
'SQUSE ME!?
EXCUSE ME!?
aww shoot!
WHAT IS HAPPENING!
HOP!
AWWWWWwwwww! AWW!
AWWWWW!
AWWWWWW!
AWW!
RAHH!
RAAAAAAHHHHHHHHHH!!!
*Swedish*
GRab the SWORD!
WOO!
*yelling in Swedish*
Aww SHOOT!
HOP!
HA ha!
OH GOD dammit!
Aw gawd damn it
HOP- fu-
lemme catch it!
almost...
[?]
WOOOAAAHHHH! WOAAH! WOAAAH!
NOOOoooo!
he he ha!
*laughing in Swedish*
This game is SO fun!
We can do, like, a longsword.
and he can hold it like THIS!
That's SO COOL, like-
you can just hold it however you want!
Like a goddamn PSYCHOPATH!
Aww, here we go.
CHOP!
*laughs like a psychopath*
[?]
*screaming in Swedish*
okay, watch this-
*more screaming in Swedish*
*ah, chi chi chi chi chuuum!*
DON'T-
don't-
[?]
You got something RIGHT there in your nose.
There you go,
fixed it for ya.
*explosion* (Dude, that's MY move)
This is how we do it in SVED!
AHHHHH!
Does this arena have any
goddamn weapons?
See, I don't even feel weird
about jumping anymore.
Oh here we go,
here's the weapon.
Dude, I got freaking err
health potions.
Aah.. I'm healed, guys.
Maybe I should try
the bow and arrow.
Okay, it works.
Alright, so you just..
like
okay.. and then
okay
alright this shouldn't be too hard
AYE you're sp-
ah ghod
ah god
ah we're doing it different
*laughing*
*swede*
OH GODDAMMIT
ay
ay ay
back off back off
okay headshot time
OOOOOOH
you're not so tough now are ya
little gurl
AHOAHHH
OH MY im on TOPof HIM
oooh that was amazing
oh woah
woah woah woah woah woah woah woah woah woah woah woah woah woah woah
stop
what'd I say
What'd I frickin' say
aye aye stop stop
stop that
*monkey noises*
Why wont you die?
honestly
you're embarassing yourself
*This is a family-friendly Christian channel*
HOAH
whew
WOAH THAT WAS AWESOME
THAT WAS AWES- HE FRICKIN DIED TOO
*there's nothing going on here, please move along*
Any last word?
Son of.. Keemstar
didn't think so
so.. so.. look guys look at this
so I pick one
and then.. I do this
Wave III, bois
lets freakin do this
*smashes shield*
SWEDISH BOY ANGRY
SWEDISH BOY KNEE ATTACK
NEVER STOP.. NEVER STOP
I got your knees, boy!
i gotchur knees
KNEE
KNEE KNEE KNEE KNEE KNEE KNEE KNEE KNEE
AHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH
KNEE, KNEE, knEE
AHHHHHHHHH
KNEE
GOD DAMN.. KNEE!
ahhh, its over...
sweet..
release..
at last
Anyway guys, hope you enjoyed this episode!
Smash like!
*wild animal has entered the chat*
Swedish boi angry
Swedish boy knee attack
Never stop
never stop
swedish boy knee attack
i got your knees boi
i got your knees
knee
knee knee knee knee knee knee
KNEES
KNEE
KNEEE
Knee
KNEE
god damn
it's over
sweet..
release..